in many problems throughout this class  we will find it useful to consider how  the mass of an object is distributed  throughout the object to do this we will  define a small piece of that object and  then consider the mass that's contained  within that small piece for an object in  one dimension the differential element  of length is Delta L and that length  contains a certain amount of mass Delta  M we could also have a linear object in  the shape of an arc or just an arbitrary  path for an object in two dimensions we  have an area element Delta a that  contains a mass Delta M for a volume we  have a volume element Delta V which  contains a certain amount of mass in  this case we can write the volume  element Delta V as the area a times this  Delta X